okay everyone prepare yourselves for two
of the most extraordinary dice rolls you
have ever seen on numberphile but before
that it's time for some more one row
yahtzee's from numberphile viewers first
of all there's this one from Justin and
Ryan they get massive bonus points for
the I love numberphile body decoration
but the question I have is did the other
guy the one who didn't roll the artsy
also have I love numberphile on his
chest just in case he was the one that
got it first we're gonna try to roll a
Yahtzee yeah for you Brady
we're gonna roll you a Yahtzee we're
gonna get this on the first shot we
promise okay attempt number one well it
wasn't yet someone oh you got four ones
and then three then very first try I got
four actually here let's do four of a
kind that's too complicated no no let's
I want to see how many look we're being
so organized now here are some more just
a reminder each person has a 1 in 1296
chance of rolling a Yahtzee dad look at
these this one comes from our friends in
Holland yes oh yeah
and okay here's a quick little moment
for all the people that used software or
computers and didn't actually roll real
dice not exactly the spirit of what
we're doing but you get geek points
Brett here included some lovely graphs
with his video
[Music]
yes only 55 rolls for this one sometimes
when people roll the artsy they they
don't quite realize they've done it like
this
81 rolls holy cow and this oh shoot
and this this video came from Iceland
[Applause]
this popsicle stick counting system
definitely caught my eye so I know the
odds for rolling 100 Yahtzee are about
one in 1296 I only have a thousand
popsicle sticks oh my god
oh my god and how's this for cool as a
cucumber there we go
five twos compared to this somewhat more
animated reaction we got a Yahtzee
you're full that did not happen
oh that was a 592 592 rolls I don't know
if I can it's about 92 or 593 rolls now
not everyone who's tried has been
successful but you can still send in the
videos like this one 10 15 20 25 30 30
36 tries and we only had two four of a
kind before that but only 36 tries it
took just like four minutes and it
should have taken like two hours now
poor old Lucas he missed the moment he
wrote his Yahtzee I think he's camera
stopped recording
but don't worry Lucas we believe you
alright
I rolled five Yahtzee but my camera
stopped recording he did it 300 it's
yeah yeah yeah 362 times he's going to
try again I'm gonna do this again
I did it I did it okay now for those two
amazing roles I was telling you about
this first one comes from James now he
upped the ante by not using a six-sided
dice but using 510 sided dice now you'll
hear his wife asking something about the
washing machine but James he's on the
brink of greatness no 34 40 oh my god
Laura it just happened
he just happened on thirty four forty
seven seven seven seven seven holy then
even the cat now gets in on the action
my quest is done
exactly can't yeah and yeah 34:40 magic
number and finally well I think this is
the most amazing role of all and it
comes from Seth who was featured earlier
in this video rolling a Yahtzee and I
think this is so amazing I'm gonna play
it twice are you kidding me are you
kidding me now if you want to watch some
of the other viewer yahtzee's on the
previous videos so put the links below
the video and on the screen you can also
see me rolling a Yahtzee
if you want to roll one yourself send me
the video you can upload it to YouTube
or send me the file email address and if
you've watched all the numberphile
videos so far why not check out sixty
symbols it's my physics channel I think
you'll like those films too
so we just rolled a Yahtzee a few
minutes ago and we decided that we're
gonna try to roll it one more time and
see if we can do two in a row because
how epic would that be so let's try it
okay so this is lucky two in a row
Yahtzee
one universe
[Music]